halo infinite is one of microsoft's
biggest upcoming games and while it
missed its original release date as an
xbox series xns launch title the
free-to-play multiplayer beta had a
surprise launch and the campaign is out
on december 8th
at e3 2019 microsoft showcased a
cinematic trailer revealing a closer
look at master chief and his new design
the sequence showed master chief being
woken up to embark on his next mission
to save the universe probably according
to microsoft the trailer included clues
and references to master chief's next
journey and fans spent months picking it
apart in search of answers of what's
coming next while story details are
being kept under wraps for now microsoft
did confirm that halo infinite will
focus more on master chief than halo 5
did as fans may recall that title
strayed from the franchise's hero with a
storyline that touched on another
character locke and even had players
fight as him for some parts of the
campaign putting more of an emphasis on
master chief is the smart call by
microsoft
it demonstrates a commitment to getting
the story right this time around with
halo infinite microsoft has acknowledged
that halo 5's campaign was a letdown so
fans will be eager to see how the story
grows and improves this time for what
it's worth microsoft is telling fans to
think of halo infinite as halo 6 instead
of some kind of spin-off or franchise
extension beyond the main storyline it
is a spiritual reboot of the franchise
according to 343 studio boss bonnie ross
we also know it takes place on zetta
halo a key location from halo lore if
you remember the story of halo is that
the ring worlds were created by another
race the forerunners as super weapons
that could wipe out sentient life in the
galaxy they were a last-ditch effort to
contain the flood a hive-minded alien
race that turns other sentient creatures
into its gross zombies remember the
library in halo combat evolved zeta halo
also known as installation 07 is where
the forerunners used human test subjects
for experiments with the flood back when
the parasites first started to show up
during the forerunner era installation
07 had some different functionality than
other ring worlds so we can probably
expect new and different structures
there and to plumb more of the backstory
of the forerunners and the race that
preceded them the precursors while
exploring the place we've also gotten a
little bit of info about the banished
the covenant splinter group sounds like
it is hell bent on wiping out humanity
once and for all probably by making use
of the halo array superweapon to do
something drastic the banished on zeta
halo seems to be led by a brute called
warchief eskerum who also looks to be
the game's antagonist master chief and
eskerom were actually both on planet
reach briefly between halo 5 and halo
infinite where chief was looking for the
weapon an ai created by spartan 2
program director dr catherine halsey
that chief plans to use to take down his
former ai companion and friend cortana
since halo 5 cortana has taken control
of ancient forerunner weapons called
guardians that she's using to control
the galaxy and place artificial
intelligences as the keepers of the
mantle of responsibility over all other
races oh boy
according to 343 you'll see some pretty
advanced ai from the banished enemies
you face in halo infinite one example of
the unconventional tactics you might
face brutes hurling grunts at you halo
infinite is taking the series back to
its beginnings in a lot of ways for one
it's set on a new ring world just like
the original game but this one will be
more explorable than in the past making
it the biggest halo environment yet
we've seen a glimpse of the map in
microsoft's halo reveal and as confirmed
in our hands-on preview you'll be able
to explore the halo ring choosing your
own path forward it'll also sport a day
night cycle and wildlife making this
ring world feel a lot more alive and
realistic than what the series has
included in the past that doesn't mean
this is going to be a non-linear game
however according to 343 telling a
traditional halo story is still a big
part of the equation so infinite also
features enclosed sections that will
feel like traditional halo set pieces
this is where a lot of the main story
will also be told one of the most
important developments about what we
know about halo infinite is that it may
well be the end of proper numbered
sequels instead 343 has said that
infinite will be the platform for the
next decade of halo which might suggest
something of an mmo-like approach where
343 continues to build on and expand
infinite with additional content over
time although it's unclear yet if this
is specifically for multiplayer or also
the story the campaign will be dropping
on december 8th but the co-op campaign
won't be available until at least may of
2022
the halo franchise's map-making feature
forge which is a favorite among fans has
also been delayed and is expected to
arrive even later than co-op skybox labs
the team behind forge and halo 5 is
taking the reins on halo infinite's
forge mode we can probably expect it to
be more robust than the halo 5 forage
but at the moment we have no idea what
features the infinite forge mode might
sport it is also worth noting that halo
infinite isn't being developed by three
for three industries alone there are at
least three other studios contributing
to halo infinite
aside from the previously mentioned
skybox the other two studios involved
are asparasoft which has contributed to
games including anthem mass effect
andromeda rainbow six siege and
assassin's creed odyssey and certain
affinity but it's unknown how the latter
two studios are contributing to the
overall game
microsoft dedicated a good amount of
time to halo infinite during its e3 2021
showcase we were introduced to a new
cortana-like ar character and there are
surely more mysteries to unravel there
but the big ticket item was multiplayer
after a few technical tests and blog
updates a surprise free to play open
beta was dropped on november 15th on
xbox series xns and on game pass for pc
and steam that's right free to play
going free to play and allowing
crossplay seems to be a great start for
infinite to keep up with the current
competition while halo no doubt remains
popular and stands today as one of the
best known fps games ever the series has
lost some ground to its contemporaries
games like call of duty war zone
fortnite and apex legends are eating a
lot of the fps pie these days and
serving a new era of players whose main
shooter experience is battle royale and
not the arena style that halo serves a
new mainline halo entry hasn't been
released on pc since 2004's halo 2.
microsoft changed his situation when it
released halo the master chief
collection on pc in 2019
setting records with the title on steam
in the process microsoft has only leaned
into the pc side of halo harder since
then adding more games to the master
chief collection while making the game
part of the xbox game pass ultimate on
pc 343 said previously that the pc
edition of halo infinite was developed
from the ground up for pc since the
launch of the multiplayer beta many fans
have been happy with the gameplay but
less happy with things like in-game
crashes and a lackluster progression
system but 343 has been quick to address
some of these issues with better xp
rewards and more updates for matchmaking
on the way the multiplayer is also
bringing competition new and returning
to tournaments that have already begun
and have shown off what high-level halo
infinite looks like during its first
month and it's still just a beta at the
time of this video chief has a few new
tactics at his disposal as well
including a grappling hook called the
grapple shot that provides you with new
traversal options you shouldn't expect
to climb everything you come across
though 343 said the grapple shot will
not turn chief into spider-man but it
should provide new options for getting
around and getting into fights there is
a lot of other new equipment as well
including a heartbeat sensor of sorts
that temporarily reveals the location of
enemies the thrust ability the repulsor
to push enemies and projectiles away and
more these new abilities we've seen
through the multiplayer may have a big
impact on the single player experience
come december
additionally halo infinite has a new
vehicle called the razorback which looks
like a beefed up warthog that has cargo
space that allows you to store things
like the flag and ctf or power seats in
stockpile mode and we also have 10 brand
new multiplayer maps at launch at least
one of the larger big team battle maps
even has a secret loot cave that can
give you some power weapons and a unique
height advantage you can't hop into
matchmaking without knowing a thing or
two about the new weapons the commando
is a precision automatic rifle with
heavy recoil but it's pretty effective
at medium to long range the skewer is a
kinetic weapon that shoots a single high
damage spike it only takes one shot to
kill normal opponents and two shots to
kill someone with an overshield the
shock rifle is a semi-automatic rifle
intended to support from a long distance
projectiles arc on impact to damage
nearby targets the stalker rifle is a
mid to long range plasma weapon with a
high rate of fire and slower projectiles
the disruptor is a short to mid-range
weapon that deals damage over time so if
you kill your opponent and they've been
shooting you with it there's a chance
you might die anyways so keep that in
mind the bulldog is a highly responsive
and fast firing tactical shotgun and it
is absolutely devastating at close range
the heatwave is a semi-automatic hard
light weapon that fires fixed
projectiles in a set pattern alt-fire
allows the wielder to change the firing
geometry so that means you can change
the crosshairs from being in a vertical
alignment to a horizontal alignment and
vice versa the ravager is a really
interesting weapon it first fires globs
of plasma but if you charge it and
unleash a big blast then it's actually
gonna lay down aoe damage and it's great
for shutting down certain choke points
or pois or flushing people out of tight
spaces the mangler is a powerful
semi-automatic brute revolver that fires
spikes at medium range and this next one
isn't exactly new but it is powerful the
needler is definitely much stronger this
time around so don't sleep on it i know
it has had the tendency to fluctuate in
its powerfulness from halo to halo but
it's really strong in halo infinite so
keep that in mind
another quick tidbit to also keep in
mind is that some of these weapons have
a spike on the actual weapon and when
you do a melee with these weapon types
you're actually going to do a little bit
more melee damage so that's a cool other
little tidbit that you should keep in
mind when you're trying out all these
new weapons halo infinite multiplayer
includes traditional 4v4 arena while big
team battle is back and it's bigger than
ever with 12b12 battles ranked arena has
its own playlists in which you begin
with a battle rifle you'll have no radar
you have to play with friendly fire on
and a few other changes from the
standard playlists if you've ever
watched halo esports then you have an
idea of what it will be like at the
moment it's my favorite playlist in the
game hands down with fiesta mode from
the fracture tenrai event being a close
second but yes absolutely ranked arenas
is super fun and where all my other onyx
players at let me know in the comments
another important element to call out is
that halo infinite has a tutorial mode
of sorts called the academy this helps
players learn the ropes and they can
even compete against bots to hone their
skills before going online to test their
medal against the masses with halo
infinite multiplayer going free to play
the game is opening up to potentially
its biggest audience yet and it's neat
to see the developers creating an
onboarding experience to help newcomers
learn the ropes and for seasoned fans
playing against bots may be a good way
to learn the ins and outs of the new
maps in a less stressful environment the
halo infinite multiplayer mode also
gives players a personal ai who serves
as a bit of a personal announcer at
times and comes in a variety of voice
and personality types
customization is also a big part of halo
infinite players can unlock and earn new
cosmetics through gameplay or they can
buy pieces outright but 343 stressed
that these items are purely cosmetic and
have no impact to gameplay a key
component of the new halo infinite
multiplayer experience is your personal
spartan that's meant to grow and evolve
month after month and season after
season three for three set players will
have more options than ever before to
customize your spartan and make it
uniquely yours each season will feature
a new assortment of customization pieces
and components that can be earned via
gameplay challenges events and purchase
we've said this before but it bears
saying again that there will be no loot
boxes or elements of chance if you
decide to purchase an optional
customization item
and of course all of halo infinite
spartan customization elements are
purely cosmetic and have no impact to
gameplay halo infinite already had its
first event alongside its current battle
pass the event was called fracture right
and ended up seeing a peak concurrent
player base on steam after it began 343
also said in a blog post with a
free-to-play service supporting
cross-play on xbox and pc along with a
more inviting new player experience
we're rolling out the red carpet for
more players than ever before it to jump
in and share in this universe and these
experiences we've all come to know and
love for nearly 20 years we're as eager
and excited as you are to begin the next
chapter of this journey together this
holiday so what are you most excited
about for the halo infinite campaign let
me know in the comments below and be
sure to like and subscribe for more halo
infinite content we'll see you all next
time
you